for me a lot of it was white right place
at the right time and but it's like i
said when you're giving you know
everyone's all you got lucky you got
this opportunity that that opportunity
but you still have to perform yeah
if you get as lucky as you want if you
get something if you don't do a good job
there you're not going to get it they
see him about actors all the time oh he
has lucky break at this yeah well yeah
but if he wasn't you know how how much
time did he take to get there doing what
was he doing and then how did he do when
he got that break because if he if he
got that part and sucked
he wouldn't have we would've never heard
of him right yeah and in your line of
work you get your ass kicked you know it
does not matter
if you go out if i got this big break i
go out there and i get knocked out it's
over
goodbye yeah luck is when preparation
meets opportunity there it is thanks
that's true it's very true do you have a
favorite fight yeah something that you
think back to like i'm so glad that's in
the books if you have to um yeah put a
gun to my head and pick one i mean i i'd
probably be beating randy the first time
yeah i beat him um this is after
ultimate fighter that was like you know
so
there's a week after we just won the
show i just won the show it was pretty
everything's all hyped up it was
probably it was the first
first fight i actually got my
pay-per-view bonus too so because we
actually hit enough big enough numbers
and we made them by a lot
so it was um
and and i event and i avenged the loss
you know i was avenging a loss and i
i
got back and i got to win by knockout i
mean it was a knockout
and close second of that was being ready
the second time because i i flew i felt
like i proved it wasn't a fluke
oh that's a flu keep you beat about yeah
because he lost first time for the
second time when i knocked around the
first round and that this proof wasn't a
fluke we wouldn't did it again
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
yeah
[Applause]